This summer we're getting honest about summer blockbusters past and present this is honest trailers blockbusters summer
Subtitle- *I am HeRe *in description at bottom
In an era where Michael Bay blew up alcatraz and
roland emmerich blew up the world
Kevin Costner only needed one bomb to blow up Universal in
Waterworld
enter the watery world known as
Waterworld a post apocalypse where everyone looks like they sleep in SpongeBob's dumpster full of makeshift vehicles resource hoarding warlords and
Here, I'll save you some time. It's Mad Max, but wet
And terrible
Geils
kevin, costner is the Mariner a hero with all the charm of a guy getting hit with a bucket of water between tags which to
Be bare. He was he's a man of few words
like really few words
My boat
In fact nobody gets to talk when he's around me
You've talked along don't shut off. You're too loud. Try sitting still
After all the time did you say something?
But this mysterious stranger has a mutant power of being super good and rope stuff
Watch this fish man out of water on a mission to save a girl from the only guy in the movie who knows how silly
It is
well
And on the way, our heroic embodiment of Florida will learn to do the right thing. Can we got a picture on the side?
What eventually?
Anytime now
Right after this
Eventually
Yep, that's the guy we're rooting for and drinking his own pee. Yep. Just as soon as he's done gargling his own piss
I'm pimping out her mom half an hour
Just gonna throw this out there are they better off with Dennis Hopper at least they get a jet ski
So take a shot of hydro top off your go juice and count your chance to
Revisit the first and last aqua Punk epic that may have been the laughingstock of Hollywood for being an expensive set sinking vanity project
But still had the seed of something really cool just cut out all the terrible dialogue better not screw up my short game
Most of the characters the story and do 20 minutes of great practical effects and real live action scenes
Perfect, oh man now I want a churro
Starring
Merman dad Murr man me as soon as I'm home from work Mariah Nanoha alone Oh
deep very deep
cheesy writer
Bordering you get one everything's here when I get back sixty-two Chin's have your chicks you the man with the dirt
Pure dirt
Wow horses boats and hoes and oh man keep the politics out of my water world
Wild wild wet
The Mariner may have taught her to swim but Napoleon Dynamite taught her to love
Have you still not seen the documentary? We made about Twilight fans who are still going hard in 2019? No will click here
Now a Robert Pattinson won't come to my birthday party
You're breathtaking
You're all
Breathtaking banner gave me the best present I could ask for a taco
new
master